[Música]
spectrum
en latinoamérica es muy difícil ser
investigador pero siempre hay una
excepción hola mi nombre es víctor
reynoso martínez tengo 20 años nací el
29 de septiembre del año 2000 en el
municipio de tultitlán estaba en mexico
me considero una persona amable honesta
respetuosa cariñosa y humilde
soy premio nacional de la juventud 2017
premio estatal de la juventud 2014 y
presea estaba méxico 2018 desde muy
pequeño era extremadamente tímido no
podía estar hablando con ninguna persona
con ningún niño con ninguna adulto
porque estaba temblando en sudán las
manos me temblaban las piernas y
tartamudear mis papás siempre han estado
muy apegados a mí por lo cual notaron
ese grave problema
sabían que más adelante en mi juventud
iba a ser muy catastrófico para mí así
que decidieron actuar mi mama siendo
maestra metió a sus chicos a una feria
de ciencias que es una feria de ciencia
es básicamente es un evento donde
jóvenes niños estudiantes presentan sus
ideas sus investigaciones
en el área científica los califican
jurados especialistas en el tema y lo
presentan frente a un público en general
ellos lo platicaban entre sí y se les
hizo una excelente idea me la platicaron
a mí y les dije que era una pésima idea
porque porque me iba a trabajar porque
la gente se iba a burlar de mí iba a
empezar a tartamudear y no quería sufrir
esa pena casi casi fue obligación
asistir a esta feria de ciencias
todo lo que les platico surgió en el año
2010 en ese año también surgió un
terrible accidente que marcó a familias
enteras y a personas entre ellas yo
en sonora murieron 52 bebés quemados en
una guardería yo soy hijo único pero
tenía una pequeña primita la cual me
daba mucho miedo perder así que me dije
a mí mismo víctor tenemos que hacer algo
para evitar que haya más niños estimados
y así fue como mediante una computadora
empecé a investigar preguntándole a mis
tropas preguntándole profesores
preguntándole a cualquier persona
especialista en el tema
fue ahí cuando empecé a desarrollar mi
proyecto una navidad sin niños quemados
este es un líquido retardante fuego a
base de las sales de fosfato el cual
ustedes se pueden aplicar en cualquier
material combustible para el fuego y
este no se quema nuestro principal
objetivo era aplicarlo en árboles de
navidad tanto naturales como
artificiales porque porque ustedes saben
que en estas épocas que se aproximan las
cuales son de diciembre nosotros
colocamos nuestros árboles de navidad
nuestros adornos las luces de navidad y
generalmente ocurren accidentes por
cortocircuitos provocados por las luces
navideñas nosotros queríamos hacer que
los árboles de navidad tanto naturales
como artificiales fueran anti fuego ya
que los probamos ahí y que funcionó de
manera adecuada hicimos otras pruebas en
diferentes materiales en cartón en
madera y plástico en papel en nuestra
propia ropa funcionó como lo esperábamos
fuimos a una colonia de escasos recursos
donde las casas eran hechas de madera de
cartón de lámina y aplicamos ese
producto han pasado ya más de 10 años y
afortunadamente en esta colonia no ha
habido ningún incidente de este tipo lo
presente en la etapa estatal gane voy a
una etapa nacional gané un pase
internacional para ir a representar a
méxico en paraguay a mis 11 años estaba
representando a mi país en paraguay ganó
el paraguay proyecto destacado y cuando
regresó mis padres me dicen zares que
víctor si quieres ya no participes
porque porque ya cumplimos nuestro
objetivo el cual era de que tú te
pudieras expresar pudieras expresar tus
ideas pudieras debatir frente a personas
ya lo lograste si quieres ya no
participes nuestro objetivo está hecho
y yo vi ahí una oportunidad muy grande
la cual fue que con estos proyectos
científicos pudiera ayudar a las
personas a mejorar su calidad de vida no
solamente de mi comunidad sino de mi
estado de mi país y obviamente del mundo
entero así que dije quiero seguir quiero
seguir en esto de las de las ferias de
ciencias y ahí fue cuando empezó toda mi
trayectoria hasta el momento de
participar más de 35 ferias a nivel
nacional e internacional tengo 8
proyectos de innovación tecnológica dos
de ellos ya patentados
seguí en esto de la investigación y creo
que todas todas las personas tenemos ese
espíritu investigador ese espíritu
científico porque porque desde niños
siempre nos preguntamos por qué ese
lápiz está ahí porque esa pluma escribe
así porque la computadora funciona de
esa manera porque los aviones vuelan
porque el cielo es azul porque en el
agua flotamos siempre hay preguntas
todos los niños tienen preguntas pero
solamente necesitamos a alguien que esté
ahí atrás de nosotros guiándonos que nos
brinde la atención que necesitamos para
solucionar esas dudas no no que ellos no
nos la respondan sino que nos den nos
encaminen hacia la respuesta
afortunadamente yo contaba con mis papás
que ellos siempre me apoyaban en todas
las locuras que yo estaba preguntando a
mí me gusta mucho observar qué sucede en
mi entorno
y en el 2015 mediante la observación
empecé a desarrollar un nuevo proyecto
el cual se llama fértil y fertilizante
sólido de lenta liberación a base de la
orina humana son pequeñas pastillas que
como su nombre lo indica es un nutriente
vegetal que se puede aplicar a cualquier
tipo de plantas a cualquier tipo de
cultivos con la intención de optimizar
su crecimiento y enriquecer el suelo
estas estas pastillas una de ellas les
dura seis meses nutriendo continuamente
su planta usted es lo único que se
tendrán que preocupar es agregarle agua
esto sucedió o esto lo inventé porque
cerca de mi casa aquí hay una parcela de
papas y por ahí corría un canal de aguas
negras yo veía que las personas
encargadas de ese cultivo extraían el
agua de ese canal y se las aplicaba en
ese cultivo la verdad me dio mucho asco
y mucho temor saber que mi familia que
mis amigos que la gente en sí estaba
consumiendo una papa una verdura una
fruta que fue regada de esa manera sabía
que iba a haber enfermedades y dije esto
no puede estar pasando tenemos que
evitar que siga esta práctica porque
sabía que no solamente se hace en
comunidad sino en todo méxico
de nueva cuenta tomé mi computadora me
acerqué con profesores me acerqué con
mis papás y empecé a desarrollar este
proyecto que les comentaba
lo presento en una etapa estatal no sin
antes sin hacer pruebas lo probamos en
diferentes cultivos en diferentes
escalas a grandes escalas
y lo colocamos en ciertas zonas
específicas donde es muy difícil
cultivar
así que como les había mencionado lo
presente en una etapa estatal ya no voy
a una etapa nacional ganó y me dan un
pase para ir a una etapa internacional
en canadá en canadá hoy y ganó medalla
de oro en el año 2016 trayendo la a
nuestro país este proyecto al empezar se
los declaro no era mi favorito sentía
que le hacía falta algo sentía que podía
mejorar en algo
pero cuando pasa todo esto sin duda se
vuelve mi favorito y se vuelve mi bebé
el que más me ha traído satisfacción el
que más me ha traído éxitos al regresar
de canadá se hace un pequeño boom de
víctor reynoso un pequeño boom de
fertiberia en redes sociales y creo que
este proyecto ese momento ha sido el
detonante cuál pues me permite estar
aquí dándoles esta pequeña charla con
este proyecto pude ir a argentina
posteriormente ganando el primer lugar
absoluto en toda la feria pude ir a
brasil a una de las ferias más grandes
del mundo ganando cuarto lugar de 700
proyectos fui a túnez en áfrica ganando
medalla de oro fui a españa ganando
tercer lugar fui a la masa con este
mismo proyecto y tuve la oportunidad de
asistir a un programa de televisión de 5
inversionistas de los mejores
inversionistas que hay en mexico
proponiéndoles esta idea de negocio
afortunadamente fue aceptada
como les digo esto ha sido toda mi
trayectoria pero no todo ha sido éxito
también he tenido derrotas pero créanme
que todas las derrotas que la he tenido
las he disfrutado al máximo porque
porque me hacen mejor persona me hacen
reflexionar me hacen llegar a mi
escritorio y pensar que hice mal y como
les digo no solamente me hizo mejor
persona sino me hizo mejor investigador
así tomando toda la retroalimentación
que me dieron los jueces me dieron
personas ajenas al jurado mejoraba mi
investigación cada vez más hasta llegar
a este punto
yo no soy una persona de mucho dinero no
soy una persona acomodada no soy una
persona que tenga todos los recursos al
alcance de su mano
para nada créanme que hago esto
para presumir ni que me alaben
no me considero un genio no soy super
inteligente créanme que aquí en el panel
de conferencistas que ustedes van a
estar observando si hay genios si hay
verdaderos genios yo solo soy un chico
que le gusta investigar que como les
digo les cut le gusta observar todo lo
que está pasando
que le gusta leer que le gusta
investigar en su computadora soy alguien
normal tengo mis amigos tengo mi
videojuego tengo salvo a diferentes
partes me gustaría tener una novia claro
xxi pero como les había mencionado
muchas veces en este camino de la
ciencia no todo el satisfacción es
sufrido bullying desde los 5 años que
recuerdo hasta este momento no solamente
por parte de mis compañeros sino de mis
propios maestros
hago esta plática para motivar a niños
jóvenes y a padres para que pongan
atención en sus hijos para que tu niño
niña joven puedan seguir luchando por
sus sueños no no quiero que se
conviertan en científicos qué bueno si
les gusta la ciencia que bueno sin más
les gusta la química como a mí pero si
no que sigan su camino en el área que
son buenos en el área que les gusta
papas no los dejen solo si tiene una
pregunta a su hijo no se la respondan
mejor díganle mira aquí tienes la
información suficiente para solucionar
tu pregunta
y ser científico y latinoamérica es
difícil si ser científico en méxico es
mucho más difícil pero créanme que no es
imposible una de las frases que me
motiva a seguir es insistir persistir
resistir y nunca desistir seamos
mexicanos que no vamos al mundo muchas
gracias